en 1943 cuando winston churchill tenía
que decidir sobre la reconstrucción de
las casas del parlamento que habían sido
bombardeadas durante la guerra dijo la
siguiente frase nosotros damos forma a
nuestros edificios y luego ellos se
encargan de moldear nos a nosotros
yo no voy a hablar de edificios hoy sino
de ciudades pero imitando a churchill
diría nosotros damos forma a nuestras
ciudades y luego ellas moldean nuestras
sociedades
y es que la forma en que desarrollamos
nuestras ciudades para bien o para mal
tiene muchísima influencia en cómo nos
desarrollamos como sociedades y es en
nuestro interés desarrollarlas lo mejor
posible para disfrutar de la mejor
calidad de vida
hoy les voy a decir
que tenemos que cambiar de rumbo
la manera en que estamos desarrollando
nuestras ciudades con una enorme
extensión una muy baja densidad una muy
pobre accesibilidad están deteriorando
nuestra calidad de vida y nuestro
desarrollo como sociedades y necesitamos
darle un giro
para poder el problema que tenemos es
que en realidad
no nos planteamos demasiado esta
cuestión no somos del todo conscientes
de dónde están los problemas y
necesitamos un marco que nos ayude a
evaluar ya comprender la dinámica y la
problemática yo propongo un marco
relativamente sencillo que se basa en
tres puntos primero entender para qué
son las ciudades
después ver qué tal cumplen y por último
a qué coste
empecemos por la función de las ciudades
en general y destilando al máximo porque
vivimos nosotros en ciudades es por las
oportunidades que nos ofrecen porque
queremos aprovechar esas oportunidades
para desarrollarnos individualmente
socialmente económicamente y es
precisamente esa proximidad esa
accesibilidad de oportunidades la que
cuenta no vale de nada que haya
oportunidades y no podamos llegar a ello
con lo cual la accesibilidad o
proximidad es la clave para que las
ciudades desarrollen su función y para
ello hay dos cosas fundamentales
densidad
y una buena mezcla de usos así de
sencillo
veamos entonces cómo hacen nuestras
ciudades para generar esa accesibilidad
en 30 años de 1985 al 2015 el mundo se
desarrolló el mundo urbano se desarrolló
muy velozmente
la población urbana mundial se
multiplicó por 2 y la superficie de las
ciudades en el mundo se multiplicó por 4
tardamos unos 12.000 años en llegar a
dos mil millones de habitantes urbanos
desde mesopotamia en 30 años duplicamos
la población urbana
el 75% de la superficie urbana en 2015
tenía menos de 30 años de antigüedad
este cambio ha sido vertiginoso la
velocidad es escalofriante pero no solo
es un cambio cuantitativo es un cambio
cualitativo también tenemos unas
ciudades que son muchísimo menos densas
de lo que eran antes de hecho esas tres
cuartas partes nuevas son del orden del
30 40% de la densidad que teníamos antes
en méxico el cambio fue aún más acusado
según un estudio de la sedesol de 1980
al 2010 en 30 años la población urbana
de méxico se multiplicó por 1.9 mientras
que la huella urbana se multiplicó por 5
con 6 ahí tenemos gráficamente que
supone esa transformación en 30 años de
nuevo
eso quiere decir que aproximadamente el
82% de la superficie urbana en méxico en
2010 tenía menos de 30 años de
antigüedad ciudad es tremendamente
nuevas
otro dato los 28 millones de nuevos
urbanitas en esos 30 años
generaron 140 millones de metros
cuadrados de vialidad nueva a casi 60
metros cuadrados de vialidad por
habitante al mismo tiempo millones de
viviendas nuevas que se construían
tenían entre 45 y 60 metros cuadrados
sólo para cuatro personas casi cuatro
personas tres con siete
uno se debiera preguntar si tiene
sentido construir casi tanta calle por
individuo como vivienda por familia
la cuestión
es
después de después de esta tremenda
expansión como hemos quedado como
ciudades
el mundo estadísticamente es ya urbano
más de la mitad de la población del
mundo se supone que vive en áreas
urbanas de hecho según naciones unidas y
el banco mundial europa eeuu méxico
rondan el 80%
esas son unas cifras de por sí bastante
abstractas porque en realidad área
urbana en qom pasa muchas realidades
área urbana incluye zonas urbanas
de este estilo zonas incluso menos
densas que estas dispersas y también
incluye lo que yo llamaría zonas
plenamente urbanas allí donde se
desarrolla una vida donde tenemos
densidad tenemos actividades varias y
sobre todo tenemos más gente en la calle
que vehículos
en el caso de monterrey por ejemplo
y el área metropolitana ocupa una
superficie aproximada de 100 mil
hectáreas que vienen a hacer mil
kilómetros cuadrados o el equivalente a
un cuadrado de 32 x 32 kilómetros
sabemos que en semejante superficie no
todo es ciudad ciudad de hecho esta es
una perspectiva típica de monterrey del
área metropolitana
les voy a dar un par de datos para
hacernos una idea de que resultado de
ciudades tenemos en el mundo
si dividiéramos
en bandas de densidad y dijéramos que de
50 habitantes por hectárea hacia abajo
estamos hablando más o menos de áreas
suburbanas o menos o dispersas y de 150
habitantes para arriba estamos hablando
de unas densidades razonablemente
urbanas
resulta que
en eeuu el 91% de la población vive en
densidad de sus urbanas o menos el 91 en
europa de ese continente de ciudades
antiguas el 72%
si miramos al otro extremo al urbano
supuestamente urbano en europa menos del
7% de la población vive en zonas con
densidades superiores a 150 habitantes
por hectárea y en estados unidos es el
2% minúsculo méxico gméxico no tengo los
datos lo más probable es que esté mucho
más cerca de eeuu que de europa pero en
cualquier caso estas cifras nos hablan
de un mundo un poco diferente a ese de
que vivimos en ciudades realmente
vivimos como raza humana a densidades
sub urbanas o menos en inmensa mayoría
a qué coste
si empezamos por ejemplo a mirar el
coste de las ciudades por la calle elijo
la calle porque la calle es uno de los
elementos de la infraestructura urbana
que más varía con la densidad a menor
densidad urbana necesitamos más
kilómetros de calle para las mismas
personas más infraestructura per cápita
y la calle es cara porque la calle no
sólo es la carpeta asfáltica o las
banquetas va todo el alumbrado todo el
mobiliario urbano y sobre todo los
servicios enterrados que suelen ser
mucho más caros
pues bien
unos datos para poner en contexto qué
quiere decir esto en chihuahua por
ejemplo hay 70 metros cuadrados de calle
por habitante en portland oregón y grant
en un momento porque me refiero a
portland 58 metros cuadrados barcelona
una de las ciudades más densas y
compactas del mundo y también con el
mejor urbano urbanismo probablemente 14
cuarta o quinta parte de lo que veíamos
en portmán chihuahua en el área
metropolitana de monterrey muy parecido
por la entre 50 y 60 porque doy estos
datos porque cuando uno mira el coste de
esta infraestructura
portland lo ha analizado en detalle y en
2016 el cálculo que tenían del coste de
reposición de las calles y sus servicios
enterrados era de unos 33 mil millones
de dólares para una población de 600 y
póco mil eran más de 50 mil dólares per
cápita
eso supone el 76% del pib de la ciudad y
estamos hablando sólo de las calles y
los servicios enterrados
la otra cosa que hicieron sand game
miraron que necesidades de inversión
tiene semejante infraestructura para
mantenerla a un nivel de servicio
aceptable analizaron lo que necesitarían
invertir frente a lo que invertían ya y
se dieron cuenta que tenían un déficit
de 430 millones de dólares más del 10%
del presupuesto municipal de portland y
portland tiene un presupuesto municipal
muy alto tenía 4 mil millones de dólares
por 600 mil personas en aquel año
la pregunta es si portland una ciudad
entre el 1% mundial en cuestión de
riqueza a forlán no le llega para
mantener sus calles esperanza puede
tener
monterrey o cualquier ciudad mexicana
méxico no puede mantener las calles en
sus ciudades
muchos de ustedes lo hayan observado
pero
y esto tengan en cuenta que sólo estamos
hablando las calles no estamos
incluyendo ningún otro activo urbano no
estamos incluyendo ni los transportes
públicos en el metro por ejemplo o
cualquier tipo de cocheras de autobuses
ni parques ni ningún tipo de edificio
público sanitario educativo
administrativo deportivo cultural
etcétera solo las calles y no llega para
las calles
pero es que no solo es insostenible sino
que en cierto modo mi pregunta es no es
también un poco absurdo chihuahua tiene
setenta metros cuadrados de calle por
habitante y tiene menos metros cuadrados
edificados por habitante como puedes
tener más calle que metros cuadrados
edificados alguno de ustedes imagina
vivir en una casa que tenga mucha más
superficie de pasillo que todas las
demás salas de la casa juntas
no parece que tenga especial sentido
pero hay más costes por ejemplo
transporte méxico es el país de la oecd
que más porcentaje del gasto familiar
dedica a moverse el 19% prácticamente
uno de cada cinco pesos lo dedican a
moverse
si miramos aquí se gasta más en moverse
que en la vivienda y sus servicios
si méxico dedicará el mismo porcentaje
que dedica españa a moverse que es un
país con ciudades más compactas se
ahorrarían las familias al año un billón
de pesos un millón de millones de pesos
que podrían hacer las familias con ese
dinero
pero hay costes peores también
tenemos
en un análisis que hacen cómo vamos en
nuevo león resulta que mirando a la
movilidad descubrieron que practican del
40% de la población mayor de edad en la
zona metropolitana no salía de casa en
un día de labor prácticamente el 40%
mayoritariamente en mujeres esta cifra
es impresionante en portland es el 12%
para que se hagan una idea en europa
típicamente es el 15% qué tipo de ciudad
tenemos que encierra en su casa a casi
la mitad de la población
hay presos que salen más a menudo que
habitantes de la zona metropolitana
dicho esto bueno y hay más costes
tenemos polución accidentes etcétera
pero me voy a quedar solo en los básicos
dicho esto como deberían ser nuestras
ciudades
pues prácticamente muchísimo más densas
y mejor mezcladas simplemente porque
porque lo que necesitamos en el día a
día lo tenemos que tener a fácil acceso
y andando y si no lo tenemos nuestras
ciudades nos estarán fallando
que implicaría en méxico en méxico esto
implicaría incrementar las densidades
urbanas entre 4 y 5 veces y reducir la
huella urbana en [ __ ] las ciudades y
cada vez que yo digo esto que hace falta
encoger las ciudades a futuras la gente
me mira en bicicleta cómo vas a encoger
si están ahí las ciudades estudios estar
loco
loco tenemos ciudades donde cuesta más
moverse que vivir ciudades que dejan
casi la mitad la población encerrada en
casa ciudades que nos matan convolución
y accidentes ciudades que disminuyen la
productividad que hacen al país más
pobre
y yo soy el loco porque sugiero que
habría que cambiar ese tipo de formato
yo creo que los problemas que tenemos
meditan otro tipo de soluciones además
pensamos en otra cosa ya que a 40-50
años la infraestructura que hemos
construido recientemente está de ella
para el arrastre porque no habrá habido
dinero para mantenerla pero no sólo la
infraestructura las viviendas todos esos
millones de viviendas pequeñas en esos
fraccionamientos que futuro tienen si
méxico dentro de 40 años tuvieron que ir
de per cápita digamos parecido al que
para tener eeuu ahora quién querría
vivir en esas viviendas
dentro de 40 años no va a haber sitio ni
para esas viviendas y no va a quedar
infraestructura de las que se está
haciendo recientemente si no
planificamos para encoger las ciudades
cómo vamos a acabar con grandes zonas
abandonadas y saltándonos y extendiendo
nos hasta el infinito no lo veo como una
fórmula adecuada pero para cambiar
tenemos dos retos críticos por un lado
la densidad
si no somos capaces tenemos una tremenda
aversión a la densidad si no somos
capaces de revertir esa aversión a la
densidad tanto socialmente como a nivel
de planeamiento no vamos a llegar a
ninguna parte pero es que demás es muy
curioso que tengamos tanta manía la
densidad porque cuando uno mira las
ciudades del mundo y mira las zonas más
densas y más céntricas resulta que se
tienden a ser las más cotizadas de las
ciudades piensen ustedes en polanco en
ciudad e méxico piensen en zonas de
manhattan en nueva yor piensen ustedes
en zonas del barrio salamanca en madrid
cómo es posible que siendo las zonas
donde los que más dinero tienen y mejor
pueden elegir eligen estar ahí que le
tengamos tanto miedo yo creo que por
desconocimiento y lo digo con
experiencia propia yo vengo de una
ciudad que realmente hoy ya no existe
esto es bilbao esto es el centro yo
crecía ahí pero cuando yo crecía ahí ahí
teníamos 600 habitantes por hectárea de
densidad hoy - hoy hay menos de 400 600
habitantes por hectárea ya no existen en
europa ni en las zonas más densas de
barcelona' que tienen los cuadros más
censos de todo europa ya no están ahí
que les puedo decir yo de esa
experiencia yo crecí ahí
y ahí tenía mi mundo a 10 minutos
andando todas las oportunidades que
necesitaba estaban ahí el colegio amigos
familiares la plaza las tiendas los
cines todo lo que necesitaba lo tenía al
lado porque eso es lo que ofrece la
ciudad compacta
segundo reto el de encoger la ciudad
este reto es complicado como en cogemos
la ciudad y como pagamos por ella
déjenme ilustrar tres posibles maneras
de recaudar dinero para ello
por un lado si compartamos las ciudades
estamos menos en transporte como decía
antes nos podríamos ahorrar casi el 5%
del pib sólo los hogares por otro lado
en ciudades más compactas menos
infraestructuras las administraciones
públicas se pueden ahorrar entre un 2 3%
del pib porque tienen menos
infraestructura y les cuestan menos los
servicios y en tercer lugar
este es el gordo
cuando dúplicas la densidad de un centro
urbano aumentas la productividad
económica porque porque las ideas se
mezclan porque se genera innovación y
aumenta el tipo de producción
méxico- duplicando dos veces la densidad
de sus ciudades podría aumentar 10% su
pib
entre un 15 y 20% del pib anual compran
5 millones de apartamentos al año
la cuestión es cómo canalizamos este
tipo de ahorros y de beneficios para
poder cambiar las ciudades que
necesitamos
la tarea es enorme la tarea es urgente y
necesitamos generar una serie de datos
para poder cambiar las políticas
yo tengo dos iniciativas que les quiero
sugerir aquí que podríamos empezar ya a
dar los primeros pasos la primera
cualquiera de ustedes lo puede hacer
acérquese al estado o al ayuntamiento
del municipio y pregunten una cosa
cuánto cuesta mi ciudad
pídeles que hagan el cálculo que miran
toda su infraestructura que hagan un
inventario completo de todo tipo de
activo público incluyendo las calles
pero también los edificios acto seguido
que calculen que vida útil tienen esos
activos y qué inversión anual necesitan
para mantenerlos para siempre y con ese
cálculo quedense y compárenlo con los
presupuestos que tienen y veremos dónde
estamos
la segunda iniciativa es un poquito más
involucrada la segunda es una ley de
responsabilidad pública si obligamos a
todas las administraciones públicas a
que encargaran a un auditor
independiente cada vez que vayan a hacer
una nueva infraestructura que les
calculé cuánto va a costar no
construirla sino mantenerla de ese
momento para siempre porque la
infraestructura pública que una vida
útil de 30 40 50 años si no inviertes te
tienes que volver a gastar el dinero
otra vez dentro 30 años cuánto cuesta
eso anualizado y obliga a las
administraciones a reservar los
presupuestos suficientes para asegurarse
que esa infraestructura va a funcionar
si hacemos eso
muchísimo más juicio y criterio a la
hora de invertir por ejemplo típico
fraccionamiento que se hace uno podría
comprobar que si las calles en el futuro
van a costar más que el predial que se
recauda simplemente no es viable
por último
para acabar
les voy a confesar que habrán podido
observar soy una persona de datos me
gustan los análisis y yo había una época
a mi vida que pensaba que con un uso
sábana análisis y muchos datos podía
convencer a cualquiera evidentemente era
inocente me he dado cuenta ha pasado el
tiempo se que somos humanos que somos
mucho más emocionales que racionales
entonces les voy a contar una decisión
vital que tira más a lo emocional que a
lo racional
mi esposa y yo vivíamos en londres
llevamos ya 13 años cuando nació nuestra
hija luca
luca nació en londres empezó a
desarrollar sus primeros años allí
londres evidentemente es una ciudad
preciosa interesante nosotros vivíamos
en una zona céntrica pero aún así no
tenía la vitalidad de las ciudades donde
nosotros veníamos ni mucho menos la
densidad la actividad en la calle en la
vida cuando nunca cumplió tres años y ya
era hora de empezar a pensar en colegios
y cómo iba a desarrollar su vida ya de
niña y en la calle tomamos la decisión
más importante en que fue levantar armas
y marcharnos de vuelta a bilbao y nos
volvimos a casa porque porque estábamos
convencidos de que iba a crecer mejor en
un entorno mucho más denso en un entorno
donde pudiera jugar en la calle en un
entorno donde tuviera otro tipo de vida
algo de este estilo nos volvimos y sin
lugar a dudas fue una de las mejores
decisiones de nuestra vida entonces
déjenme preguntar a ustedes qué quieren
ustedes dónde quieren vivir ustedes pero
ustedes y sus hijos y sus nietos más
allá de nosotros aquellos que van a
venir como quieren que vivan en ciudades
hostiles ciudades que nos roban la vida
ciudades que nos quitan la salud
ciudades que no nos permiten
desarrollarnos como nosotros mismos
imagino que no si no quieren eso les
animo mañana mismo vayan ustedes al
ayuntamiento y pregunten cuánto cuesta
su ciudad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]